being mediocre is insulting if you care
about your life than being mediocre
should be insulting at the risk of
offending you I'm using strong language
intentionally this has to be important
to you if it's important then you'll
change if it's important you'll make it
a priority it's important you'll face
your fears if it's important you'll stop
making excuses when something is truly
deeply important to you you will find
ways to make it happen
even when the little man tells you it's
not possible if it's not important to
you then you won't do anything about it
you'll continue doing exactly what
you're doing now being mediocre is easy
anybody can do it and most people and
companies do following your passion
being crazy enough to try to change the
world and standing for something
important are hard so most people in
companies don't and thus most businesses
are mediocre too they're boring and
uninspiring you haven't made people care
enough about what you're doing I mean
really care
feel it in their bones care tell all
their friends about you care tap to your
logo on their body care even if you get
halfway to that level of care you'll be
way ahead of your competition right now
if someone lowers their prices by 10%
you lose your customers because everyone
is selling the same products and
services because there isn't really all
that much that separates you from your
competition there is no strong customer
loyalty because you're not inspiring and
hey
you're not alone the fortune 500 list
was first pruned in 1955 only 13% of
those companies on that original list
are still on the list today 13%
builders have faded away because they
were born and lost relevancy most
businesses are boring do you want to
know the first step to having a
remarkable business here's where it all
begins and your life and business will
change forever you need to find your
greatness
you